>>Nicole: As a K-5 teacher, we
understand that it's really important
to integrate the curriculum
as much as possible.
So if you're doing a lesson in the
computer lab, if it's combining some
of the reading skills, writing
skills, language art skills,
or their knowledge about
a certain subject area,
I think that it makes
learning a lot more meaningful.
>>Nicole: A few years ago,
the District had to do a lot
of cutbacks on tech spending.
And I started to see that
there was an advantage
of using the cloud-based,
or free web apps.
And anybody who has a computer or
internet, they can access them,
not only from school, but at home,
so my goal is to get them so excited
that they go home and continue
on with their learning.
For example, they can do their
digital art, or digital drawings
in programs such as Sumo Paint, or
Psycho Paint inside of Google Docs,
Google Drawing, PhotoSketch,
SketchUp.
Those are just a few
choices that I give them.
>>Student: This is a list
of different applications
that you can use to like
make music or do art.
It's just a variety of them
that Ms. Dalesio put together.
>>Nicole: And then we also
take advantage of a lot
of the free software that comes
built into our Apple computers,
so we utilize iLife
a lot for our photo
and video editing inside
of iMovie, or in iPhoto.
And we also use things like
Garage Band and iTunes for them
to do their audio recordings
or create music.
>>Nicole: You know, you get your
ingredients together in the folder,
and then when you mix them together,
this is what you're doing in iMovie.
And then when you export it out, it's
sort of like you're baking the cake.
>>Nicole: I gave them
several choices
on the assignment that
they had to do.
And all of them had to use iMovie.
The first one was to make
a life story with pictures
from their childhood
under three minutes.
And another one was that
they could do a poem.
And another choice was that they
could create a tutorial explaining a
concept that they had learned,
they knew how to do,
such as a math concept.
And then the other one was that
they could do a personal narrative
or other fictional story
that they had written,
and turn that into video
in under 90 seconds.
>>Nicole: And what's
your project about?
>>Student: I did this
personal narrative,
and I went to this place
called Pismo Beach.
>>Nicole: Oh, okay, so you did
the story about Pismo Beach.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Nicole: Where are the photos that
you're going to use for that project?
>>Student: They're on the
server and in the iMovie folder.
>>Nicole: Okay, perfect,
so you already transferred
them over from home?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Student: Well, we have to
make like a movie project.
So you kind of have a topic,
and with your topic you speak
into a microphone, and
then you draw pictures
to go with what you're saying.
>>Student: Sad is the
color of dark blue.
Sad sounds like sobbing
and deep misery.
Sad feels as heavy as sharp bricks.
Sad smells like tears
on a damp pillow.
>>Student: When I go in the lab
and do like an iMovie project.
And I'm just going to do
one of these poems in here.
And I'm going to-- there's
this thing called "Kid Pics."
I'm going to like load it on,
like into little like sections.
Put it all together, and I'm going
to put music in the background,
and I'm probably going to talk
about it, too, a little bit.
>>Student: And then look at your
audio, and you put it in iTunes.
>>Student: So go to
this, put all your--
>>Student: They're in order.
>>Student: No, but
put them all together.
>>Nicole: If you create
an environment
where they can collaborate with each
other, then they get better ideas
with each other, but also they help
each other to finish their projects.
>>Student: My story
is about basketball.
Right now I'm working on adjusting
how long each photo is going to take,
and seeing where I need
to place the photos.
>>Nicole: You've got the writing
skills and the reading skills
and the speaking skills
and the technology skills
collaborating with each other.
Organization skills all put together.
>>Student: We both
were doing tutorials.
We got the audio first
recorded outside.
And then we took a screen
recording of what we were doing
on like this painting website.
And we like just filmed what we
were going to show on the tutorial.
Then on iMovie we put the video
and mixed it with the audio.
And cut off some portions of audio
or clipped some portions of video
for it to kind of match up.
>>Student: Cool technique, huh?
Okay, now we can try
something a little bit harder.
How about, I guess, 25 times 25.
>>Nicole: How many people got
their iMovie projects uploaded
and on their digital portfolios?
>>Nicole: And then the
next thing would be able
to share it with other people.
I think it makes it all the more
meaningful in terms of if they think
that somebody else might see it,
you know, you have the whole concept
of the authentic audience.
Another important concept that
I want students to know is
that it's not just me teaching them.
We're all here to teach each other.
And each one of us is, you
know, a citizen in this class,
and I want them to participate
and contribute to their learning.
So definitely want to encourage them
to be sharing and to collaborate
with others and to always
be a lifelong learner.